[Música]
con nuestro segundo invitado del día me
hablamos de la nueva estrategia de rusia
en la guerra en ucrania esto tras el
anuncio del presidente vladimir putin de
movilizar 300 mil reservistas además de
apoyar los referendos de adhesión a
rusia de las regiones de lugansk daniels
gerson y saboree y ahora si damos
entonces la bienvenida a antonio barrios
obviado analista especialista en
conflictos internacionales y origen
ampliación de la otan gracias por estar
con nosotros antonio esta mañana de
miércoles en directo américa de francia
24 hablemos de las implicaciones de esta
movilización de más de 300 mil
reservistas para pelear en la guerra en
ucrania como se lee este anuncio del
presidente ruso vladimir putin
bueno de alguna manera es parte del
revés que hace poco rusia tuvo en donde
las tropas de ucrania lograron recuperar
algunos de los territorios que tienen
frontera natural con rusia y eso
evidentemente algo interno desde el
punto de vista político le ha traído
algunos problemas a vladimir putin lo
cual pues de alguna manera ha tenido que
replantear todo todo el esquema militar
y el envío de estos vistas pues es una
forma de ver cómo evita nuevos reveses
ante estos avances que ha tenido
ucrania en algunos territorios ya
ocupados por rusia entonces esto uno
podría leerlo como parte de la
reorganización militar quizás nuevos
objetivos militares que se han planteado
y eso es parte pues un poco de ver cómo
lograr recuperar o por lo menos evitar
más pérdidas de territorio como el que
recientemente ocurrió hace menos de una
semana así las cosas antonio usted
entonces estaría dando cuenta que está
perdiendo lo ganado en la guerra no
algunos territorios pero así está están
está medición de fuerzas que ucrania
también está cada vez más confiada en la
pregunta ción de basta de conflicto con
ucrania pues es dando pasos firmes con
esta contraofensiva contra rusia bueno
habría que abrir solamente el tiempo
podría llegar a determinar si si esta
contraofensiva ucranianas es sostenible
en el tiempo
uno podría incluso intuir de alguna
manera de que pudo haber habido algún
tipo de fisura respecto en el frente
oriente que ha estado dominando rusia
desde la invasión en febrero de este año
y habría que ver si esta contraofensiva
pues va a ser sostenida en el tiempo y
si eso va a implicar eventualmente que
rusia iba a ir gradualmente obteniendo
cada vez más ganancias territoriales
frente a la ocupación que tiene rusia
así que eso solamente en el tiempo se
puede llegar a medir putin digamos
podría tener problemas internos en su
país en su gobierno y su gabinete
militar a por estas decisiones por lo
que estamos viendo digamos esta
contraofensiva ucraniana cada vez más
exitosa recuperando territorios y
responda mento para luego pues ahondar
un poco también en lo de los referendos
si hay o hay un detalle muy muy
interesante porque hay dos grandes
bandos que han estado en choque y esto
se acentuó con la pérdida de este
territorio recuperado por ucrania hay un
grupo que se llama los civil y que es
todo el sector burócrata que es muy
fuerte que ha liderado precisamente por
dimitri medvediev y están los siloviki
que es la línea dura encabezada
precisamente por vladimir putin todo el
sector de inteligencia todo el sector
militar
es la gente que llevo a putin a la
invasión de febrero entonces todo se
está esta pugna se ha acentuado cada vez
más con lo ocurrido recientemente y la
toma del territorio por parte de ucrania
lo cual pues evidentemente pues todo
este replanteamiento militar está
tratando putin de ver cómo logró un
balance y cómo logra un poco calmar las
aguas a lo interno de todo su gabinete a
lo interno de la estructura política y
militar dentro de rusia ahora sé antonio
vamos con lo que ocurrió ayer y también
el apoyo del presidente ruso vladimir
putin porque recordemos que esta nación
de alguna manera comenzó cuando también
se declararon dependientes las
repúblicas de danielle y lugar se van a
realizar estos referendos el día 23
desde el 23 mejor dicho hasta el 27 de
septiembre de una edición a rusia por
parte del territorio controlado en estas
regiones sería el inicio de una ofensiva
muy fuerte en estos territorios qué
jugada quiere hacer moscú con todo esto
que se está llevando a cabo en estas
cuatro regiones
yo creo que este es un acto desesperado
yo creo que el tema de los referendos
eso estaba para algunos meses después
incluso se estaba pensando que esto
podría ser diciembre enero del otro año
pero el agilizar estos referéndum que
está proponiendo no solamente los
líderes locales pro rusos en estos
territorios a orillas el lugar con este
ejercicio es precisamente para poder
acelerar eventualmente un tipo de guerra
formal en la cual la presencia de tropas
rusas dentro de estos territorios una
vez que sean anexados a la federación
constitutiva de rusia le podría podría
cambiar el curso completamente de la
guerra de seguir tratar de convertir a
ucrania en una nación que eventualmente
continuaría la guerra sobre esos
territorios que originalmente se harían
parte de la federación de rusia y eso le
permitiría a la sopa de rusia o a putin
dar la orden de una guerra más formal en
defensa de estos territorios y esto
podría eventualmente sin duda alargar la
guerra esto sería quizás eventualmente
una declaración formal de guerra contra
y convertiría automáticamente a ucrania
en una nación agresora sobre estos
territorios que serían parte de la
federación de rusia con lo que está
diciendo antonio entonces el presidente
vladimir putin pasaría de llamar la
operación especial en un gran y
movimientos tácticos digamos especiales
a realmente decir que si se está en
guerra con ucrania de masa cuál es la
implicación del cambio de solamente esta
palabra no a nivel de organización bueno
tiene mucho porque eso ya implicaría no
solamente una declaración formal de
guerra sino que implicaría ya una
reorganización completamente de las
tropas o del ejército sobre lo que
consideran que deben defender ya dentro
de ucrania y eventualmente quizás una
continuación de la toma de territorios
en caso de que ucrania acentúe sus
ataques para la recuperación de esos
territorios independientemente del
referendo 1 recordemos que hacerles que
ya hace escasas horas había manifestado
que evidentemente así iba a ser así ha
sido también la posición de la comunidad
internacional de que no va a haber
reconocimiento de este referéndum porque
implica pues en la partición del
territorio ucraniano la pérdida de los
territorios y el presidente selenski
puede ser reiterada en algunas
oportunidades ya de que la guerra va a
continuar sea por la fuerza o cualquier
otra forma porque no va a reconocer el
efecto de este de este referéndum así
las cosas del diálogo está totalmente
descartado para una posible solución a
este conflicto también lo digo porque
pues varios líderes mundiales en el
marco de la asamblea 77 de naciones
unidas han hablado por supuesto del
conflicto en ucrania después de resolver
todo por la vía del diálogo también
puede hacer unas reformas dentro del
consejo de seguridad en esa concordancia
no para para tratar de resolver
realmente los conflictos en curso si se
puede considerar que hay punto muerto
porque a pesar de este esfuerzo
internacional de terminar la guerra por
la vía negociada putin persiste en la
idea de la ocupación territorial y de
este referéndum para analizar estos
territorios mientras que el presidente
selenski habla del no reconocimiento
está reparando y por tanto la wii la
guerra va a continuar tal cual así que
estas posiciones están contrapuestas
tanto de putin como de sevens que hacen
inviable la posibilidad de cualquier
propuesta a nivel internacional que haga
una salida negociada a esta guerra
prácticamente ya para finalizar nuestra
conversación antonio de cara al invierno
quien se vería beneficiado con esta
época tan fría en ese territorio bueno
hay todo un mito histórico en la
historia militar de lo que ha
significado este estado cuando se habla
del tema
michelle y matiko pero definitivamente
no hay garantía definitiva de que ante
todo ese mito que se ha hablado pues no
hay garantía de que rusia tenga este la
seguridad total de que esto le puede
llegar a beneficiar o incluso lo habló a
los ucranianos así que una cosa es lo
que en el pasado pudo haber ocurrido con
ciertos conflictos en los que rusia se
tuvo que ver involucrado sobre todo en
la segunda guerra mundial y otra cosa es
lo que pueda llegar a ocurrir con este
conflicto son porque han habido cambios
tecnológicos en las estrategias cambian
las tácticas cambian y eso no
necesariamente pues implica que rusia la
tenga segura respecto a lo que el curso
de la guerra nuclear y en este momento
todo ha sido muy incierto también muy
inesperado antonio al principio también
se creía que rus podría ganarle en
cuestión de días este territorio que
quería de ucrania mira llevamos más de
seis meses de guerra ahorita y ucrania
está haciendo una contraofensiva exitosa
recuperando parte de su territorio rusia
ya reconoció que más de seis mil
soldados murieron está llamando a sus
reservistas entonces pues una guerra que
todo puede pasar hasta el momento no nos
ha cumplido digamos las predicciones
después el poderío militar de rusia con
el ucraniano vemos que la moral de la
ucrania no en este caso ha podido a lo
mejor un poco más que todo el poderío
militar y táctico y la experiencia
también en guerra de rusia